[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend hinein die grünen haben zwei
neue parteivorsitzende und einen berg
aufgaben vor sich wie schnell das
knirschen und steuern kann wenn man
einerseits in der regierung macht hat
und andererseits aus der partei
forderungen das canon ältere grüne nur
zu gut der frühere parteichef reinhard
bütikofer hat dem früheren außenminister
joschka fischer jedenfalls keine träne
nachgeweint als alles zu ende war
joschka ist weg grün geht weiter sagte
er damals und
charismatiker begeistern sie sind aber
auch anstrengend wer bock und herr beck
sind noch da und zwar sehr dominant und
die neuen chefs ricarda lang und omid
nouripour müssen ihnen jetzt den rücken
frei halten und gleichzeitig der partei
ein eigenes gesicht geben vom parteitag
in berlin berichtet benjamin gorzawski
ihre freundin freunde herzlichen dank
für diese große vertrauen das natürlich
verpflichtet
es ist halb sechs am abend als die neue
grünen spitze feststeht ja ich nehme die
wahl an vielen vielen dank ich mit knapp
76 prozent für lang und 82 prozent für
lou reed uhr eher respektable als
wirklich gute ergebnisse aber das gefühl
in der halle ist hauptsache geschafft
ricarda lang 28 jahre alt geboren in
filderstadt ist parteilinke steht für
die themen feminismus und soziale
gerechtigkeit aber auch netzthemen
bewegen sie wie body shaping jeder soll
so sein dürfen niemand sein will weil
ein crooner erkrankt spricht ricarda
lang von zuhause aus per video schalte
ich sehe aus wie ich aussehe und ich bin
verdammt stolz
politik in einer partei zu machen in der
nichts davon darüber entscheidet was mir
politisch zugetraut wird
omid nouripour 46 jahre wurde in teheran
geboren er ist real sein thema die
außenpolitik die grünen möchte er zur
führenden kraft der linken mitte machen
wir werden den wahlkampf zusammen nach
arbeiten um das nächste mal noch
erfolgreicher zu sein und auch
strukturen zu schaffen die uns
ermöglichen mit geschlossenheit und mit
den erfolgen die wir erzielen werden
wieder in der k-frage mitspielen zu
können den glanz der über figuren
berbalk und harbeck haben die neuen
vielleicht noch nicht die aufgabe ist
jedenfalls gewaltig der eigenen
regierung klarmachen was die partei
fühlt und vermitteln ich glaube wir
haben ein super team an der spitze der
partei und das braucht man auch weilen
die erfahrung haben wir schließlich
schon mal gemacht als wir in der
bundesregierung waren wir sind dann
erfolgreich in der exekutive wenn die
partei auch selber lebendig und treiben
bleibt und das traue ich diesem team zu
der parteitag wählte außerdem noch emily
büning zur nachfolgerin von
bundesgeschäftsführer kellner jetzt im
wirtschaftsministerium ein großer
neuanfang also für eine partei mit
riesigen herausforderungen
der neue grünen chef dürfte der erste in
dem amt seien der leidenschaftlich
wrapped in frankfurt ist auch schon mal
in einem rapper wettbewerb angetreten am
ende platz acht um mit nouripour guten
abend
für alle die sie jetzt noch nicht kennen
drei adjektive die sie beschreiben und
an denen sie sich vielleicht auch messen
lassen würden
bemüht stets immer
okay aber das klingt jetzt noch nicht so
nach jetzt geht's los sondern erst nach
richtig ich werde es versuchen und
vielleicht klappt es nicht
naja das war ja jetzt meine innereien
die hier raus gekippt habe aber die
konstellation ist jetzt geht's los wir
sind jetzt endlich in der regierung
haben hart dafür gearbeitet jahre lang
das war überfällig und jetzt werden wir
liefern müssen und jetzt geht's los
sie sind vielflieger eine klima sünde
die sie nicht lassen können danach
wurden sie gefragt ihre antwort war
langstreckenflüge was passiert wenn sie
sowas auf dem parteitag sagen
die leute wissen dass sich außenpolitik
gemacht habe die leute wissen dass wir
mal nach brasilien fährt in die amazonas
um leuten die dort für den schutz ihrer
lebensräume kämpfen auch helfen will
dass man auch dahin muss und das nicht
nur vom schreibtisch aus machen kann ich
habe das schon mal vom parteitag gesehen
gesagt und die leute hatten verständnis
dass wir die frage ist nicht das
individuelle verhalten oder dass wir
strukturell einkommen das endlich co2
ausstoß der menschheit verkleinert wird
und wir auf diesem planeten überleben
können man merkt schon sie sind jetzt
als realo quasi die connection von
burgund habeck in die partei ihre
kollegin ricaner lang kümmert sich dann
um die fundis beide haben dieselbe
aufgabe nämlich oppositionsforderungen
mit der realität in einklang zu bringen
wie managed man das
frau lang hat sich für die linke
kandidiert nicht für die realo sondern
wir beide verbunden ist 90 die grünen
wir haben dieselbe aufgabe haben
dieselbe partei für die wir sprechen und
wir werden uns engstens abstimmen mit
unseren regierungsmitgliedern und dann
wird es klappen mit dem liefern
geschlossenheit ist natürlich das gebot
gerade in der regierung und wir werden
das koordinieren müssen zusammen es gab
ja in der vergangenheit wenn man
zurückkommt wird schon mal dieses
dilemma wenn man so will das die
regierenden grünen ihre partei quasi
überfahren haben das ende war dann nicht
so gut für beide wenn sie sich das
werden sie genau studiert haben haben in
dem ich mal an was können sie daraus
lernen für sich selbst
die geschichte die sie erzählen ist
jetzt aus dem jahr 98 dass es jetzt
glaube ich nach meinem hessischen abitur
24 jahre her die partei ist in einem
anderen modus wir haben zehn
landesregierungen in denen wir auch
kompromisse schließen das entscheidende
ist dass wir auch die langfristigen
perspektiven beschreiben und natürlich
erklären was wir denn für kompromisse
warum geschlossen haben wir haben kein
tempolimit weil wir dafür den
kohleausstieg vor ziehen konnten
trotzdem wollen wir in vier jahren und
spätestens ein tempolimit haben gibt es
einen punkt an dem sie als parteichef
gegenüber ihren grünen ministern sagen
würden stoppt das geht nicht
ich gehe nicht davon aus dass das
gebraucht wird meine beiden jetzt
ehemaligen parteivorsitzenden sind jetzt
in der regierung die wissen ganz genau
wie die partei tickt die kennen auch die
sensibilitäten die kennen kann es genau
die dna dieser partei wir werden
einheitlich miteinander sein es wird
nicht darum gehen dass die partei jetzt
irgendwie gelbe karten verteilt sondern
wir werden gemeinsam in verschiedenen
rollen aber abgesprochen jetzt in dieser
regierung zum erfolg kommen europol dann
ist da noch so eine sache dass sich der
scheidende bundesvorstand jetzt
staatsanwaltschaftlichen ermittlungen
ausgesetzt sieht da geht es um den
verdacht der untreue im raum steht mal
an sie ganz persönlich sie sind nicht
davon betroffen aber machen sie ganz
persönlich gefragt wenn sie wenn jemand
in einem gremium entscheidet bei dem sie
auch teil sind und sagt hey wir bekommen
jetzt alle 1500 euro corona bonus hätten
sie da gesagt freunde bitte ohne mich
ich glaube dass man einfach jetzt heute
nicht mehr fahren nachvollziehen kann
mit welcher geschwindigkeit wie viele
entscheidungen dort getroffen werden
mussten in den wahlkampf eb noch nie
hatten vorher es gab natürlich auch den
politischen schaden es gab auch einen
preis wenn die gesamte partei bezahlt
hat allen voran natürlich auch annalena
baerbock und robert habeck und jetzt
haben wir den juristischen abschluss
lassen und die staatsanwaltschaft macht
ihre arbeit ist auch richtig so gut aber
ende august
unterbrechen ich hatte ja gefragt was
was müssen was merkt man da was denkt
man sich da so wenn jemand sagt okay wir
schließen jetzt für uns selbst ein
corinna bonus hat das nicht schon gleich
von anfang an egal wie der wahlkampf
läuft so ein bisschen geschmäckle
ich glaube dass das was daraus lernt und
das war glaube ich die frage ist dass
man jetzt strukturen aufbaut die auch
dem großen wachstum der aufgaben gerecht
wird und dass es korrektive gibt die
solche dinge die dann nicht hätten
basieren sollen auch verändert sagt omid
nouripour der neue grünen chef ich danke
für das gespräch
danke
und das gespräch haben wir aus
termingründen am abend aufgezeichnet das
größte außenpolitische problem das sich
nicht nur der grünen außenministerin
stellt das brodelt 1500 kilometer weiter
im osten hanna ganz genau wir schauen
auf die spannungen zwischen russland und
der ukraine wegen der die usa nun
weitere truppen in osteuropäischen nato
staaten verlegen will das hat us
präsident joe biden angekündigt das
werde sich aber nur um eine geringe zahl
von soldaten handeln unterdessen hat
russland begonnen erste militärtechnik
nach belarus zu bringen laut dem
russischen verteidigungsministerium für
eine militärübung mitte februar das
manöver soll auch im süden von belarus
abgehalten werden der an die ukraine
grenzt
aus dem 450 euro job soll bald ein 520
euro job werden das hat
bundesarbeitsminister heil angekündigt
am ersten oktober soll die
verdienstgrenze für minijobs angehoben
werden da dann auch der mindestlohn auf
12 euro steigt sonst hätten millionen
geringfügig beschäftigte ihre
stundenzahl reduzieren müssen kritik
kommt von den gewerkschaften sie
befürchten dass die mini jobs immer mehr
reguläre arbeitsplätze verdrängen
sérgio material wird nun doch italiens
staatsoberhaupt bleiben
im achten wahlgang wurde er heute mit
einer deutlichen mehrheit wiedergewählt
nachdem alle vorherigen wahl runden ohne
sieger geblieben waren erklärte sich der
80-jährige für eine zweite amtszeit
bereit obwohl er dies eigentlich zuvor
ausgeschlossen hatte mehrere parteien
hatten materieller darum gebeten
weiterzumachen
portugal ist eines der länder das wir in
der korona pandemie mit einer ganz
besonderen mischung aus sorge und neid
betrachten wir haben die bilder im kopf
von krankenwagen die sich vor
überfüllten intensivstationen staunen
wir haben wenig später bilder gesehen
wie sie in portugal bei bier und kaffee
schon wieder lachend in der sonne sitzen
während deutschland den lockdown
debattiert jetzt hat omikron das
wunderschöne land an europas westzipfel
fest in seiner gewalt fast ein zehntel
der bevölkerung ist in quarantäne oder
isolation und gleichzeitig sollen die
portugiesinnen und portugiesen morgen
ein neues parlament wählen
wie das geht zeigt thomas walde aus
lissabon wenn der wähler nicht zuordnen
können kommt die urne zu den wählern
mitarbeiterinnen des portugiesischen
heimatschutzes besuchen menschen die
kogit haben oder kontakt fälle sind und
sich isolieren müssen stimmabgabe vor
dem wahltag an der haustür erste formen
dieser wahlvorgang ist für die menschen
in den altersheimen vorgesehen und für
diejenigen die an co wird erkrankt sind
und zu hause in quarantäne sind
jeder zehnte in portugal hat derzeit co
wird oder ist kontakt fall eine
briefwahl gibt es nicht und vor allem
ältere haben angst sich im wahllokal
anzustecken die großstädte ich bin sehr
zufrieden dass sie unsere wahlstimme
abholen es ist wichtig dass wir wählen
wenn es diesen service nicht geben würde
hätten viele leute nicht gesehen
danach so ist das viel sicherer für uns
wenn alle leute das so machen könnten
würden auch alle wählen gehen
auch inhaltlich ist co wird das
bestimmende thema dieser wahl
portugal ist nur schwer durch die
pandemie gekommen es gibt eine
wirtschaftliche und soziale krise und so
sind es wirtschaftsthemen die den
wahlkampf bestimmen
die sozialisten von premierminister
antonio costa hier beim
wahlkampfabschluss in lissabon wollen
die sozialen folgen der pandemie mildern
und den wohlfahrtsstaat ausbauen
wir haben jetzt schon eine
arbeitslosigkeit die niedriger ist als
vor der pandemie das heißt wir sind
bereit für die vollständige erholung der
wirtschaft die liberal- konservativen
dagegen wollen steuern senken um die
wirtschaft nach der pandemie wieder
anzukurbeln
diese wahlentscheidung ist extrem
wichtig für unser land trotzdem handeln
sie ist ein wendepunkt denn portugal
bekommt milliarden aus europäischen
fonds und muss nun damit die weichen für
die zukunft stellen ein model feature so
führt kurve zu einer richtungswahl wer
im parlament die mehrheit bekommt um die
wahlbeteiligung zu erhöhen erlaubt die
regierung auch cupid infizierten an die
urnen zu gehen sie sollen das zwischen
18 und 19 uhr tun weil unklar ist wie
viele portugiesen trotz co wird an die
urnen gehen gilt auch der ausgang der
wahl als völlig offen
es ist der erste heimsieg seit 44 jahren
die australierin ashley partie hat die
australian open gewonnen die nummer eins
der tennis-weltrangliste siegte in
melbourne gegen die us-amerikanerin denn
je collins mit 6 zu 3 und 7 zu 6 für die
25-jährige war die es ist der dritte
grand-slam-titel nach den french open
2009 10 und wimbledon im vergangenen
jahr
und die lottozahlen diese samstags die
lauten 23 15 17 24 26
superzahl 7 alle angaben wie immer ohne
gewähr
wegen eines sturmtiefs über der nordsee
gibt es in norddeutschland massive
probleme im bahnverkehr
mehrere fernverbindungen mussten
kurzfristig wegen sturmschäden gesperrt
werden sie seien laut bahn nun aber
wieder befahrbar trotzdem können es
weiterhin zugausfälle und verspätungen
geben denn die nächsten stunden bleiben
stürmisch der deutsche wetterdienst
warnt vor orkanartigen böen im nordosten
deutschlands sowie an der nord und
ostseeküste dort kann es vereinzelt auch
zu orkanböen kommen zudem gibt es eine
sturmflutwarnung für die nordsee und die
ostsee
und jetzt zu den wetteraussichten für
morgen im norden und osten schwerer
spuren teils mit orkanböen im
tagesverlauf nachlassen dazu im osten
und süden einige regen schnee und
graupelschauer sonst häufig sonne drei
bis neun grad am montag kräftige
schneefälle teils bis in tiefe lagen
dazu im westen sturmböen auch am
dienstag und mittwoch sehr wechselhaft
und stürmisch in den mittelgebirgen und
am alpenrand ergiebigen neuschnee wie
neuschnee das wird auf jeden fall eine
unruhige nacht erst mal für viele von
ihnen wir sind morgen wieder für sie da
hier um 21 uhr 45 im heute journal
die nächsten nachrichten gibt es hier um
mitternacht in der heute express von uns
zweien im namen des gesamten teams
einander
[Musik]